Wow.
That's a lot of options.
However, by making a list of
what we needed in a tool,
one of them stands out for
our current purposes.
InVision is the right tool for
us, right now.
I want to delve a bit into
the strengths of the tool to make clear
why we're choosing to use it.
First, I want to take
a look at interactivity.
We've already mentioned this is key for
medium fidelity prototypes.
And it turns out that inVision
has a concept of Hotspots,
which maps directly onto our
concept of interaction points.
To make our prototype interactive,
all we need to do is
take our list of interaction points and
make a hotspot for each of them.
That bring us the speed.
InVision allows you to
simply import your mocks or
wire frames into the tool,
which combines with that hotspot idea
to make building these
prototypes a very fast process.
And then, it's main strength,
Remote Feedback is key to this tool.
We'll talk more later about
what this looks like.
But for now, all you need to know is
that inVision allows us to do user
research like we did with Carl, but
with someone half a world away.
We can do that either in real
time with a LiveShare or
asynchronously with a Share Link.
That's pretty great.